friends this party the Liberal Democrats
we have now been in government for 500
days not easy is it none of us thought
it would be a walk in the park but I
suspect none of us predicted just how
tough it would turn out to be we've lost
support we've lost seats and we lost a
referendum I know how painful it has
been to face anger and frustration on
the doorstep some of you may even
wondered will it'll be worth it in the
end it will be and today I want to
explain why now down in Westminster
we've been vilified like never before
the left and the right I tell you they
didn't like as much in opposition and
they like us a whole lot less now we're
in government the left accuse us of
being powerless puppets duped by a
right-wing conservative cleat and the
right accuse us of being a sinister
left-wing cleat who duped powerless
conservatives I just wish they'd make up
their minds so yes it's been hard and
adversity tests the character of a party
just as it tests any person we've shown
you shown immense strength after being
hit hard we picked our cells up and we
came out fighting fighting to keep the
NHS safe fighting to protect human
rights fighting to create jobs fighting
for every family not not doing the easy
thing but doing the right thing not easy
but right right now of course our
biggest concern
is the economy the recovery is fragile
every worker every family knows that
there is a long hard road ahead just in
the last few days alone we've seen a
financial storm in the eurozone rising
unemployment falling stock markets so we
were right to pull the economy back from
the brink it's clearer now than ever
that deficit reduction was essential to
protect the economy to protect homes and
jobs because deficit reduction it lays
the foundations for growth but on its
own it's not enough and that's why we're
already investing in infrastructure
reducing red tape promoting skills
getting the banks lending but the
outlook outlook for the global economy
has got worse so we need to do more we
can do more and we will do more for
growth and jobs after the summer riots
message broads sprang up they became
known as peace walls and on the peace
wall in Peckham there was a note that
simply read our home our children our
future six words that say so much more
than 600 speeches our home our children
our future Britain is our home we will
make it safe and strong these are our
children we will tear down every barrier
they face and this is our future we
start building it today